okay so what are we going to do for
today so the main content for today is
to
um
go through
sort of more stuff about word vectors
including touching on word sensors and
then introducing the notion of neural
network classifiers um so our biggest
goal is that by the end of today's class
you should feel like you could
confidently look at one of the word
embeddings papers such as the google
word to vect paper or the glove paper or
sanjiv aurora's paper that we'll come to
later and feel like yeah i can
understand this i know what they're
doing and it makes sense so let's go
back to where we were um so
this was sort of introducing this model
of word devec and
third
line your idea was that we started with
random word vectors and then we're going
to sort of it we have a big corpus of
text and we're going to iterate through
each word in the whole corpus and for
each position we're going to try and
predict what words surround this our
center word and we're going to do that
with a probability distribution that's
defined in terms of the dot product
between the word vectors for the center
word and the context words
um and so that will give a probability
estimate of a word appearing in the
context of into well actual words did
occur in the context of into on this
occasion so what we're going to want to
do is sort of make it more likely that
turning problems banking and crises will
turn up in the context of into and so
that's learning updating the word
vectors so they can predict actual
surrounding words better
um
and then the thing that's almost magical
is that doing no more than this simple
algorithm this allows us to learn word
vectors that capture well word
similarity and meaningful directions in
a word space
so more precisely right for this model
the only parameters of this model are
the word vectors so we have outside word
vectors and center word vectors for each
word and then we're taking their dot
product um to get a probability well we
get taking a dot product to get a score
of how likely a particular outside word
is to occur with the center word and
then we're using the soft max
transformation to convert those scores
into probabilities as i discussed last
time and i kind of come back to at the
end this time
a couple of things to note um this model
is what we call an nlp a bag of words
models so bag of words models are models
that don't actually pay any attention to
word order or position it doesn't matter
if you're next to the center word or a
bit further away on the left or right
the probability estimate would be the
same
and that seems like a very crude model
of language that will offend any
linguist and it is a very crude model of
language and we'll move on to better
models of language as we go on but even
that crude model of language is enough
to learn quite a lot of the probability
sorry quite a lot about the properties
of words
and then the second note
is well with this model
we want it to give
reasonably high probabilities to the
words that do occur in the context of
the center word at least if they do so
at all often but obviously lots of
different words can occur so we're not
talking about probabilities like 0.3 and
0.5 we're more likely going to be
talking about probabilities like 0.01
and numbers like that
well how do we achieve that and well the
way that the word defect model achieves
this and this is the learning phase of
the model is to place
words that are similar in meaning
close to each other in this high
dimensional vector space so again you
can't read this one but if we scroll
into this one
we see lots of
words that are similar and meaning group
close together in the space so here are
days of the week like tuesday thursday
sunday and also christmas
over
what else do we have
we have
samsung and nokia this is a
diagram i made quite a few years ago so
that's when nokia was still an important
maker of cell phones we have various
sort of fields like mathematics and
economics
over here so we group words that are
similar in meaning
actually one more note i wanted to make
on this i mean again this is a
two-dimensional picture which is all i
can show you on a slide um
and it's done with the principal
components projection that you'll also
use in the assignment um
something important to remember but hard
to remember is that high dimensional
spaces have very different properties to
the two dimensional spaces that we can
look at and so in particular
a
word a vector can be close to many other
things in a high dimensional space but
close to them on different dimensions
okay so i've mentioned
doing learning so the next question is
well how do we um learn good word
vectors and this was the bit that i
didn't quite hook up at the end of last
class so for a while in the last i said
calculus and we have to work out um the
gradient of the loss function with
respect to the parameters that will
allow us to make progress um but i
didn't sort of altogether put that
together so what we're going to do
is um we start off with random word
vectors we initialize them to small
numbers near zero in each dimension
we've defined our
loss function j which we looked at last
time and then we're going to use a
gradient descent algorithm which is an
iterative iterative algorithm that
learns to maximize j of theta by
changing theta and so the idea of this
algorithm is that
from the current values of theta you
calculate the gradient j of theta and
then what you're going to do is make a
small step in the direction of the
negative gradient so the gradient is
pointing upwards and we're taking a
small step in the direction of the
negative of the gradient to gradually
move down towards the minimum
and so one of the parameters of neural
nets that you can fiddle in your
software package is what is the step
size so if you take a really really itsy
bitsy step it might take you a long time
to minimize the function you do a lot of
wasted computation on the other hand if
your step size
is much too big
well then you can actually diverge and
start going to worse places or even if
you are going downhill a little bit that
what's going to happen is you're then
going to end up bouncing back and forth
and it'll take you much longer to get to
the minimum
okay in this picture i have a beautiful
quadratic
and it's easy to minimize it something
that you might know about neural
networks is that in general they're not
convex so you could think that this is
just all going to go alright um but the
truth is and practice life works out to
be okay
but i think i won't get into that more
right now and come back to that um in
the later class
so this is our gradient descent so we
have the current values of the
parameters theta we then walk a little
bit in the negative
direction of the gradient using our
learning rate or step size alpha and
that gives us new parameter values where
that means that you know these are
vectors but for each individual
parameter we are updating it a little
bit by working out the partial
derivative of j with respect to that
parameter
so that's the simple gradient descent
algorithm nobody uses it and you
shouldn't use it
the problem is that our j is a function
of all windows in the corpus remember
we're doing this sum over every center
word in the entire corpus and we'll
often have billions of words in the
corpus
so actually working out j of theta or
the gradient of j of theta would be
extremely extremely expensive because we
have to iterate over our entire corpus
so you'd wait a very long time before
you made a single gradient update and so
optimization be extremely slow
and so
basically a hundred percent of the time
in neural network land we don't use
gradient descent we instead use what's
called stochastic gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent is a very
simple modification of this so rather
than working out an estimate of
the gradient based on the entire corpus
you simply take one center word or a
small batch like 32 center words and you
work out an estimate of the gradient
based on them
now that estimate of the gradient will
be
noisy and bad because you've only looked
at a small fraction of the corpus rather
than the whole corpus but nevertheless
you can use that estimate of the
gradient to update your theta parameters
in exactly the same way and so this is
the algorithm that we can do and so then
if we have a billion word corpus um we
can if we do it on each center word we
can make a billion updates to the
parameters we pass through the corpus
once rather than only making one more
accurate
update to the parameters
at once you've been through the corpus
so overall
we can learn
several orders of magnitude more quickly
and so this is the algorithm that you'll
be using everywhere
including um you know right right from
the beginning from our assignments
um
again just an extra comment of more
complicated stuff we'll come back to all
right
this is
the gradient descent is a sort of
performance hack it lets you learn much
more quickly it turns out it's not only
a performance hack neural nets have some
quite counter-intuitive um
properties and actually the fact that
stochastic gradient descent is kind of
noisy and bounces around as it does its
thing it actually means that in complex
networks it learns better um solutions
than if you were to run
plain gradient descent very slowly so
you can both compute much more quickly
and do a better job
okay
one final note on running stochastic
gradients with word vectors this is kind
of an aside
but something to note is that if we're
doing a stochastic gradient update based
on one window then actually in that
window we'll have seen almost none of
our parameters because if we have a
window of something like
five words to either side of the center
word we've seen at most 11 distinct word
types so
we will have gradient information for
those 11 words but the other 100 000 odd
words now vocabulary will have no
gradient update information so this will
be a very very sparse gradient update
so if you're only
thinking math
you can just
have your entire gradient and use the
equation that i showed before
but if you're
thinking systems optimization
then you'd want to think well actually i
only want to update the
parameters for a few words and there
have to be and there are much more
efficient ways that i could do that
um
and so um
here's so this is another aside will be
useful for the assignment so i will say
it
up until now when i presented word
vectors i presented them as column
vectors
and that makes the most sense if you
think about it as a piece of math
whereas actually
in all
common deep learning packages including
pytorch that we're using
word vectors are actually represented as
row vectors and if you remember back to
the representation of matrices and cs107
or something like that um that you'll
know that that's then obviously
efficient um for representing words
because then you can access an entire
word vector as a contiguous range of
memory
different if you're in fortran anyway so
actually our
word vectors will be row vectors
when you look at those um inside pi
torch
okay now i wanted to say a bit more
about the word to vec algorithm family
um and also um what you're going to do
in homework 2. um so if you're still
meant to be working on homework 1 which
remembers um to next tuesday that really
actually with today's content we're
starting into homework two and i'll kind
of go through the first part of homework
two today and this other stuff you need
to know for homework two so i mentioned
briefly the idea that we have two
separate vectors for each word type the
center vector and the outside vectors
and we just average them both at the end
they're similar but not identical for
multiple reasons including the random
initialization and the stochastic
gradient descent um
you can
implement
a word defect algorithm with just one
vector per word and actually if you do
it works slightly better
but it makes the algorithm much more
complicated and the reason for that is
sometimes you'll have the same word type
as the center word and the context word
and that means that when you're doing
your calculus at that point you've then
got this sort of messy case that just
for that word you're getting an x
squared term oh sorry a dot product
you're getting a dot product of x dot x
term which makes it sort of much messier
to work out and so that's why we use
this sort of simple optimization of
having two vectors per word
okay
so
for the word to vect model as
introduced in the miklov at our paper in
it wasn't really
just one
algorithm it was a family of algorithms
so there are two basic model variants
one was called the skip gram model which
is the one that i've explained to you
that
predicted for outside words position
independent given the centre word
in a bag of words style model the other
one was called the continuous bag of
words model sibo and in this one you
predict the center word from a bag of
context words
both of these give similar results the
skipgram one is more natural in various
ways so it's sort of normally the one
that people have um
gravitated to in subsequent work
um but then as to how you train this
model
um what i've presented so far is the
naive softmax equation
which is
a simple but relatively expensive
training method and so that isn't really
what they suggest using in your paper in
the paper they suggest using a method
that's called negative sampling so an
acronym you'll see sometimes is sgns
which means skip grams negative sampling
so let me just um say a little bit um
about what this is but actually
doing the script gram model with
negative sampling is the part of
homework too so you'll get to know this
model well so the point is that if you
use this naive softmax you know even
though people commonly do use this naive
softmax in various neural net models
that working out the denominator is
pretty expensive and that's because you
have to iterate over every word in the
vocabulary and work out
these dot products so if you have a
hundred thousand word
um
vocabulary you have to do a hundred
thousand dot products um to work out the
denominator and that seems a little bit
of a shame and so instead of that the
idea of negative sampling is where
instead of using
this soft max we're going to train
binary logistic regression models for
both the troop
the true pair of center word and
the context word
versus
noise pairs where we keep the true
center word and we just randomly sample
words from the vocabulary
so as presented in the paper
the idea is like this so overall what we
want to
optimize is still
an average of the
loss for each particular center word but
for when we're working out the loss for
each particular center word we're going
to work out um sorry the loss for each
particular center word and each
particular window we're going to
take the dot product as before of the
center word and
the outside word and that's sort of the
main quantity but now instead of using
that inside the softmax we're going to
put it through
the logistic function which is sometimes
also often also called the sigmoid
function the name logistic is more
precise so that's this function here so
the logistic function is a handy
function that will map any real number
to a probability
between zero and one open interval so
basically if the dot product is large
the logistic of the dot product will be
virtually one
okay so we want this to be large and
then what we'd like is on average we'd
like the dot product between the center
word and words that we just chose
randomly i.e they most likely didn't
actually occur in the context of the
center word to be small
and there's just one little trick
of how this is done which is this
sigmoid function
is symmetric and so if
um
we want
this probability to be small we can take
the negative of the dot product so we're
wanting it to be over here that the
product the dot product of a random word
in the center word is a negative number
and so then we're going to take the
negation of that and then again once we
put that through the sigmoid we'd like a
big number
okay so the way they're presenting
things they're actually maximizing this
quantity but if i go back to making it a
bit more similar to the way we had
written things
we've worked with
minimizing the negative log likelihood
um so it
it looks like this so we're taking the
negative log likelihood of
this the sigmoid of the dot product um
again negative log likelihood we're
using the same negator dot product
through the sigmoid and then we're going
to work out this quantity for a handful
of brand
number we k negative samples um and how
likely they are to sample word depends
on their probability and where this loss
function is going to be
minimized given this negation by making
these dot products large and these dot
products um
smalling negative
so
they're just then
one other trick that they
use actually there's more than one other
trick that's used in the word defect
paper to get it to perform well but i'll
only mention one of their other tricks
here um when they sample the words they
don't simply just sample the words based
on their um probability of occurrence in
the corpus or uniformly what they do is
they start with what we call the unigram
distribution of words so that is
how often words actually occur in our
big corpus so if you have a billion word
corpus and a particular word occurred 90
times in it you're taking 90 divided by
a billion and so that's the unigram
probability of the word but what they
then do
is that they take that to the
three-quarters power and the effect of
that three-quarters power which is then
re-normalized to make a probability
distribution with z kind of like we saw
last time with the soft max by taking
the three-quarters power
that has the effect of dampening the
difference between common and rare words
um so that less frequent words are
sampled somewhat more often but still
not nearly as much as they would be
if you just use something like a uniform
distribution over the vocabulary
okay so
that's basically um everything
to say
about
the basics of how we have this very
simple
neural network algorithm
word deveck and how we can train it and
learn word vectors
so for the next bit what i want to do is
step back a bit and say well here's an
algorithm that i've shown you that works
great um
what else could we have done and what
can we say about that um and the first
thing that you might think about is well
here's this
funny iterative algorithm
to give you
word vectors
um you know if we have a lot of words
and a corpus
it seems like a more obvious thing that
we could do
is just look at the counts of how words
occur with each other and build a matrix
of counts uh
co-occurrence matrix so here's the idea
of a
co-occurrence matrix so i've got a teeny
little corpus i like deep learning i
like nlp i enjoy flying
and i can define a window size i made my
window simply size one to make it easy
to fill in
my matrix
symmetric just like our word to back
algorithm and so then the
counts in these cells are simply how
often things that co-occur in the window
of size one so i like
occurs twice
so we get twos in these cells because
it's symmetric
deep learning occurs one so we get
one here and lots of other things occur
zero so we can build up a co-occurrence
matrix like this and well
these actually give us a representation
of words as
co-occurrence vectors so i can take the
word i
with either a row or a column vector
since it's symmetric and say okay my
representation of the word i
is this row vector
and that is a representation of the word
i
and i think you can maybe convince
yourself that to the extent that words
have similar meaning and usage you'd
sort of expect them to have somewhat
similar vectors right so if i had the
word u as well on a larger corpus you
might expect i and u to have similar
vectors because i like you like i enjoy
you and joy um you'd see the same kinds
of possibilities hey chris could you
keep looking to answer some questions
sure
all right so we got some questions from
negative uh sort of the negative
stamping sampling slides
um
in particular
what's like can you give some intuition
for negative sampling what is the
negative sampling doing and why do we uh
only take one positive example those are
two questions that could be answered in
tandem
okay um that's a good question okay i'll
try and give more intuition so
is to work out something like what the
softmax
did
in a much more
efficient way
um
so in the soft max well
you wanted to give high probability to
the
in predicting the context a context word
that actually did appear with the center
word um and well the way you do that is
by having the dot product between those
two words be as big as possible
and
part of how but you know you're going to
be sort of it's more than that because
in the denominator you're also working
out the dot product with every other
word in the vocabulary so as well as
wanting the dot product with the actual
word that you see in the context to be
big you maximize your likelihood by
making the dot products of
other words that weren't in the context
smaller because that's shrinking your
denominator
and therefore um you've got a bigger
number coming out and you're maximizing
the loss so even for the softmax the
general thing that you want to do
to maximize it is have
dot product with words action the
context big
dot product with words not in the
context be small to the extent possible
and obviously you have to
average this as best you can over all
kinds of different contexts because
sometimes different words appear in
different contexts obviously
so
um so
the negative sampling is a way of
therefore trying to maximize the same
objective now you know for
you only
you only have one positive term because
you're actually wanting to use the
actual data um so you're not waiting
wanting to invent data so for working
out the entire j we do
do work this quantity out for every
center word and every context word so
you know we are iterating over the
different
words in the context window and then
we're moving through positions in the
corpus so we're doing different vcs so
you know gradually we do this but for
one particular center word and one
particular context word we only have one
real piece of data that's positive so
that's all we use because we don't know
what other words
should be counted as positive words now
for the negative words
you could just sample
one
negative word and
that would probably work but if you want
a sort of a slightly
better more stable sense of
okay we'd like to
in general have other words have low
probability it seems like you might be
able to get better more stable results
if you instead say let's have
10 or 15 sample negative words and
indeed that's been found to be true
but and for the negative words well it's
easy to sample any number of random
words you want and at that point it's
kind of a probabilistic argument the
words that you're sampling
might not be actually bad words to
appear in the context
they might actually be other words that
are in the context but 99.9
of the time they will be unlikely words
to occur in the context
and so they're good ones to use and yes
you only sample 10 or 15 of them but
that's enough to make progress because
the center word is going to turn up on
other occasions and when it does you'll
sample different words over here so that
you gradually sample different parts of
the space and start to learn
we had this co-occurrence matrix and it
gives a representation of words as
co-occurrence vectors
and just one more note on that i mean
there are actually two ways that people
have commonly made these co-occurrence
matrices
one corresponds to what we've seen
already that you use a window around a
word
which is similar to word to vec
and that allows you to capture some
locality and some of the sort of
syntactic and semantic proximity that's
more fine-grained the other way these
co-matrix
diseases have often made is that
normally documents have some structure
whether it's paragraphs or um just
actual web pages sort of sized documents
so you can just make the your window
size a paragraph or a whole web page and
count co-occurrence in those and this is
the kind of method that's often been
used in information retrieval in methods
like latent semantic analysis
okay so the question then
is are these kind of count
word vectors
good things to use well
people have used them they're not
terrible
but they have certain problems
the kind of problems that they have uh
well firstly they're huge though very
sparse so this is back where i said
before if we had a vocabulary of half a
million words when then we have a half a
million dimensional vector for each word
which is much much bigger than the word
vectors that we typically use
um
and it also means that because
we have these very high dimensional
vectors um that we have a lot of
sparsity and a lot of randomness so the
results that you get tend to be noisier
and less robust depending on what
particular stuff was in the corpus
and so in general people have found that
you can get much better results by
working with low dimensional vectors so
then the idea is we can store the most
of the important information about the
distribution of words in the context of
other words in a fixed small number of
dimensions giving a dense vector
and in practice the dimensionality of
the vectors that are used are normally
somewhere between 25 and a thousand
and so at that point we need to use two
we need to use some way to reduce the
dimensionality of our count co
occurrence vectors
so
if you have a good memory
from a linear algebra class
you hopefully saw singular value
decomposition and
it has various mathematical properties
um that i'm not going to talk about here
of single singular value projection
giving you an optimal way under a
certain definition of optimality of
producing a reduced dimensionality
matrix that maximally or
sorry pair of matrices that maximally
well lets you recover the original
matrix
but the idea of the singular value
decomposition is you can take any matrix
such as our
count matrix and you can
decompose that into
three matrices u
a diagonal matrix sigma and a v
transpose matrix
um
and this works for any shape now
in these matrices some parts of it
are never used because since this
matrix is rectangular there's nothing
over here and so this part of the the
transpose matrix gets ignored but if
you're wanting to get smaller
dimensional representations
what you do is take advantage of the
fact that the singular values inside the
diagonal sigma matrix are ordered from
largest down to smallest so what we can
do is just delete out more of the matrix
of the delete out some singular values
which effectively means that in this
product
sum of u
and sum of v is also not used and so
then as a result of that we're getting
lower dimensional representations
um
for
our words if we're wanting to have word
vectors
which still do as good as possible a job
within the given dimensionality
of enabling you to recover the original
co-occurrence matrix
so from a linear algebra background um
this is the obvious thing to use
so how does that work
um well if you just build
a
raw count co-occurrence matrix
and run svd on that and try and use
those as word vectors it actually works
poorly and
it works poorly
because if you get into the mathematical
assumptions of svd you're expecting to
have
these normally distributed errors and
what you're getting with word counts
looked not at all
like something's normal you didn't
because you have exceedingly common
words like arthur and and and you have a
very large number of rare words so that
doesn't work very well but you actually
get something that works a lot better
if you scale the counts in the cells
so
to deal with this problem of extremely
frequent words there are some things we
can do we could just take the log of the
raw counts
we could kind of cap the maximum count
we could throw away the function words
and any of these kind of ideas let you
build then have a co-occurrence matrix
that you get more useful word vectors
from running something like svd
and indeed these kind of models were
explored um in the 1990s and in the
2000s and in particular um doug rhody
explored a number of these ideas as is
how to improve the co-occurrence matrix
in a model that he built that was called
kohl's
and you know actually in his kohl's
model
he observed the fact that you could get
the same kind of
linear components that have semantic
components that we saw yesterday when
talking about
analogies so for example this is a
figure from his paper and you can see
that we seem to have a meaning component
going from a verb to the person who does
the verb so drive to drive a swim to
swimmer teach the teacher marry to
priest and that these
vector components are not perfectly but
are roughly
parallel and roughly the same size and
so we have a meaning component there
that we could add on to another word
just like we did for previously for
analogies we could say drivers to driver
as mari is to what and we'd add on this
screen vector component which is roughly
the same as this one and we'd say oh
priest so that this space could actually
get some
word vectors
analogies right as well
and so that seemed
really interesting to us around the time
word to vec came out of wanting to
understand better what the iterative
updating algorithm of word deveck did
and how it related to these more linear
algebra based methods that have been
explored
in the couple of decades previously and
so for the next bit i want to tell you a
little bit about the glove algorithm
which was an algorithm
for word vectors that was made by
jeffrey pennington richard socher and me
in 2014
and so the starting point of this was to
try to connect together
the
linear algebra based methods on
co-occurrence matrices like lsa and
coles with the models like skip grand
sibo and their other friends which were
iterative neural updating algorithms so
on the one hand you know
the linear algebra methods actually
seemed like they had advantages for fast
training and efficient usage of
statistics
but
although there had been work on
capturing
word similarities with them by and large
the results weren't as good perhaps
because of disproportionate importance
given to large accounts in the main
conversely
um
the models
um the the neural models it seems like
if you're just doing these gradient
updates on windows you're somehow
inefficiently using statistics versus a
co-occurrence matrix
but on the other hand
it's actually easier to scale to a very
large corpus by trading
time for space and but
at that time it seemed like the newer
methods just worked better for people
that they generated improved performance
on many tasks not just on word
similarity and that they could capture
complex patterns such as the analogies
that went beyond word similarity
and so what we wanted to do was
understand a bit more as to what do you
what properties do you need to have this
analogies work out as i showed last time
and so
what we realized was that if you'd like
to do
have these sort of vector subtractions
um and
additions
work for an analogy the property that
you
um want is for meaning components so a
meaning component is something like
going from
male to female queen to king or going
from
its age and truck to driver um that
those meaning components
should be represented as ratios of
co-occurrence probabilities
so here's an example that shows that
okay so suppose the meaning component
that we want to get out is
the spectrum from solid to gas as in
physics
well
you'd think that
you can get at the solid part of it
perhaps by saying does the word co-occur
with ice and the word solid occurs with
ice so that looks hopeful and gas
doesn't occur with ice much so that
looks hopeful but the problem is the
word water will also occur a lot with
ice and if you just take some other
random word like the word random it
probably doesn't occur with ice
much
in contrast if you look at
words co-occurring with steam
solid won't occur with steam much but
gas will
but water will again and random will be
small
so to get out the meaning component we
want of going from
gas to solid what's actually really
useful is to look at the ratio of these
co-occurrence probabilities
because then we get a spectrum
of large to small between solid and gas
whereas for water in a random word it
basically cancels out and gives you one
um i just wrote these numbers in but if
you
count them up in a large corpus it is
basically what you get so here are
actual co-occurrence probabilities and
that for
water and my random word which was
fashion here these are approximately one
um whereas for
the ratio of
probability of co-occurrence of solid
with ice or steam is about ten and four
guess
it's about a tenth
so
how can we
capture these ratios of coeconos
probabilities as linear meaning
components so that in our word vector
space we can just add and subtract
linear meaning components
well
it seems like the way we can achieve
that is if we build a log by linear
model so that the dot product between
two word vectors
attempts to approximate the log of the
probability of co-occurrence
so if you do that you then get this
property
that the
difference between two vectors
its similarity to another word
corresponds to the log of the
probability ratio shown on the previous
slide
so the glove model wanted to try and
um
unify the thinking between the
co-occurrence matrix models and the
neural models
by
being in some way similar to a newer
model but actually calculated on top of
a
current matrix count
so we had an explicit loss function
and our explicit loss function
is that we wanted the dot product to be
similar to the log of the co-occurrence
we actually added in some bias terms
here but i'll ignore those for the
moment and we wanted to not have very
common words dominate and so we kept the
effect of high word counts
using this f function that's shown here
and then we could
optimize this j function
directly on the co-occurrence
count matrix so that gave us fast
training scalable to huge corpora
um and so this algorithm worked
very well
so if you ask
if you run this algorithm ask what are
the nearest words to frog you get frogs
toad and then you get some complicated
words but it turns out they are all
frogs um until you get down to lizards
so latoya's that lovely tree frog there
um
and so this actually seemed to work out
pretty well
how well did it work out um to discuss
that a bit more i now want to say
something about how do we evaluate word
vectors
are we good for up to there for
questions
we've got some questions uh what do you
mean by an inefficient use of statistics
as a con for skip gram
well
what i mean is
that
you know
for word to vac you're just you know
looking at one center word at a time and
generating a few negative samples and so
it sort of seems like
doing something always precise there
whereas if you're doing uh
optimization algorithm on the whole
matrix at once well you actually know
everything about the matrix at once
you're not just looking at what words
what other words occurred in this one
context of the center word you've got
the entire vector of co-occurrence
accounts for the center word and another
word and so therefore you can much more
efficiently and less noisily
work out how to minimize your loss
okay
i'll go on
okay so
i've sort of said look at these word
vectors they're great and i sort of
showed you a few things at the end of
the last class which argued hey these
are great um you know they work out
these analogies um they show similarity
and things like this um we want to make
this a bit more precise
and indeed for natural language
processing as in other areas of machine
learning a big part of what people are
doing is working out good ways to
evaluate knowledge that things have
so how can we really evaluate word
vectors so in general for nlp evaluation
people talk about two ways of evaluation
intrinsic and extrinsic so an intrinsic
evaluation
means that you evaluate directly on the
specific or intermediate subtasks that
you've been working on so i want a
measure where i can directly score how
good my word vectors are and normally
intrinsic evaluations are fast to
compute they helped you to understand
the component you've been working on but
often
simply trying to optimize that component
may or may not have a very big good
effect on the overall system that you're
trying to build
um so people have also also been very
interested in extrinsic evaluations so
an extrinsic evaluation is that you take
some real task of interest to human
beings whether that's web search or
machine translation or something like
that and you say your goal is to
actually improve performance on that
task well that's a real proof that this
is doing something useful so it in some
ways it's just clearly better
but on the other hand it also has some
disadvantages
it takes a lot longer to
evaluate on an extrinsic task because
it's a much bigger system and sometimes
you know when you change things
it's unclear whether the fact that the
numbers went down was because you now
have worse word vectors or whether it's
just somehow the other components of the
system
interacted better with your old word
vectors and if you change the other
components as well things would get
better again so
in some ways it can sometimes be muddier
to see if you're making progress
but i'll touch on both of these methods
here um so for intrinsic evaluation of
word vectors
one way
um which we mentioned last time was this
word vector analogy so we could simply
give our models a big collection of word
vector analogy problems so we could say
man is the woman as king is the what and
ask the model to find the word that is
closest using that sort of word analogy
computation and hope that what comes out
there is queen
and so that's something people have done
and have worked out an accuracy score of
how often that you are right
at this point i should just mention one
little trick of these word vector
analogies that everyone uses but not
everyone talks about a lot in the first
instance i mean
there's a little trick which you can
find in the sim code if you look at it
that when it does manage to woman as
king
is to
what
something that could often happen
is that actually the word once you do
your pluses and your minuses that the
word that will actually be closest is
still king
so
the way people always do this is that
they don't allow one of the three input
words um in the selection process so
you're choosing the nearest word that
isn't one of what words
um okay
so since
um here is showing results from the
glove vectors um so the glove factors
have this strong linear component
property just like i showed before um
for
um
coal so this is for
the male female dimension and so because
of this you'd expect in a lot of cases
that word analogies would work because i
can take the vector difference of man
and woman and then if i add that vector
difference onto brother i expect to get
to sister
and king queen and from any of these
examples but of course they may not
always work right because if i start
from emperor it's sort of on a more of a
lean and so it might turn out that i get
countess or duchess coming out instead
you can do this for various different
relations so different semantic
relations so
these sort of word vectors actually
learn quite a bit of just world
knowledge um so here's the company ceo
or this is the company ceo around
2010 to 2014 when the data was taken
from
word vectors
and they as well as semantic things or
pragmatic things like this they also
learn syntactic things so here are
vectors for positive comparative and
superlative forms of adjectives and you
can see those also um move and roughly
linear components um so um the word to
vect people built a data set of
analogies so you could evaluate
different models on the accuracy of
their analogies
and so
here's how you can do this and this
gives some numbers so there are semantic
and syntactic analogies i'll just look
at the totals
okay so what i said before is if you
just use unscaled
co-occurrence counts
and pass them through an svd things work
terribly and you see that there you only
get 7.3 but then as i also pointed out
if you do some scaling you can actually
get svd
to of a scaled count matrix to work
reasonably well so this spdl is
similar to the kohl's model and now
we're getting up to 60.1 which actually
isn't a bad score right so you can
actually do a decent job without a
neural network um and then here are the
two variants of the
um word to vect model and here are our
results
from the glove model and of course at
the time
2014 we took this as absolute proof
that our model was better and our more
efficient use of statistics was really
working in our favor um with seven years
of retrospect i think that's kind of not
really true it turns out i think the
main part of why we scored better is
that we actually had better data and so
there's a bit of evidence about that on
this next slide here so this looks at
the
semantic syntactic and overall
performance on word analogies of glove
models that were trained on different
subsets of data so in particular the two
on the left are trained on wikipedia
and you can see that training on
wikipedia makes you do really well on
semantic analogies which maybe makes
sense because wikipedia just tells you a
lot of semantic facts i mean that's kind
of
what encyclopedias do
and so one of the big advantages we
actually had was that wikipedia
that the glove model was partly trained
on wikipedia as well as other texts
whereas the word to vect model that was
released was trained exclusively on
google news so newswire data and if you
only train on a smallish amount of
newswire data you can see that for the
semantics it's it's just not as good as
even a
one-quarter of the size amount of
wikipedia data though if you get a lot
of data you can compensate for that so
here on the the right hand did you then
have common crawl web data and so once
there's a lot of web data so now 42
billion words um you're then starting to
add good scores again from the semantic
side
um the graph on the right then shows how
well do you do as you increase the
vector dimension and so what you can see
there is you know 25 dimensional vectors
aren't very good they go up to sort of
50 and then 100 and so 100 dimensional
vectors already work reasonably well so
that's why i used hundred dimensional
vectors
when i showed my example in class yet
is the sweet spare too long load and
working reasonably well but you still
get significant gains for 200 and it's
somewhat to 300 so at least back around
so 2013 to 15 everyone sort of
gravitated to the fact that 300
dimensional vectors is the sweet spot um
so almost frequently if you look through
the best known sets of word vectors that
include the word divec vectors and the
glove vectors that usually what you get
is 300 dimensional word vectors
um that's not the only intrinsic
evaluation you can do
another intrinsic evaluation you can do
is see how
these models model human judgments of
word similarity um so psychologists for
several decades have actually
taken human judgments a word similarity
where literally you're asking people for
pairs of words like professor and doctor
to give them a similarity score that's
sort of being measured as some
continuous quantity giving you a score
between say 0 and ten um and so there
are human judgments which are then
averaged over multiple human judgments
as to how similar different words are so
tiger and cat is pretty similar um
computer and internet is pretty similar
plane and car is less similar stock and
cd aren't very similar at all but stock
and jaguar even less similar
so we could then say
for
the our models do they have the same
similarity judgments and in particular
we can measure a correlation coefficient
of whether they give the same ordering
of
similarity judgments and so then we can
get data for that and so there are
various different data sets of word
similarities and we can score different
models as to how well they do on
similarities and again
you see here that plain svds
and works comparatively better here for
similarities than it did for analogies
you know it's not great but it's now not
completely terrible
because we no longer need that linear
property but again scaled svds work a
lot better
word deveck works a bit better than that
and we got some of the same kind of
minor advantages from the glove model
hey chris sorry to interrupt a lot of
the students were asking if you could
re-explain the objective function for
the glove model and also what log
bilinear means
okay
uh
sure
okay here is
here is my here is my um objective
function the right if i go so one slide
before that right so the property that
we want
is that we want the dot product
um to represent the log probability of
co-occurrence
so
um and that's then gives me my tricky
log bilinear so the buy is that there's
sort of the wi and the wj so that there
are sort of two
linear
things and it's linear in each one of
them so this is sort of like having and
rather than having a sort of an ax where
you just have something that's linear
in x and a is a constant it's bilinear
because we have the w i w j and there's
linear in both of them and that's then
related to the log of a probability and
so that gives us the log by linear model
and so
since we since we'd like these things to
be equal
what we're doing here if you ignore
these two center terms is that we're
wanting to say the difference between
these
two is as small as possible so we're
taking this difference and we're
squaring it so it's always positive and
we want that
squared term to be as small as possible
and you know that's 90 percent of it and
you can basically stop there but the
other bit that's in here
is a lot of the time
when you're
building models um rather than simply
having sort of an ax model it seems
useful to have a bias term which can
move things up and down
for
the word in general and so we add it
into the model bias term so that there's
a bias term for both words so if in
general probabilities are high for a
certain word this bias term can model
that and for the other word this bias
term then model it
okay
so now i'll pop back
and after
um
oh actually i just saw someone said why
multiplying by the f of
sorry i did skip that last term
um
okay the why modifying by this f of x i
j so this last bit was
to
scale things depending on the frequency
of a word because
you want to
pay more attention
to
words that are more common or word pairs
that are more common because you know if
you think about it um in word divect
terms you're seeing
if things have a co-occurrence account
of 50 versus
you want to do a better job at modeling
the co-occurrence of the things that
occurred together 50 times
and so
you want to consider in the count of
co-occurrence
but then the argument is that that
actually leads you astray when you have
extremely common words like function
words and so effectively you paid more
attention
to
words that co-occurred together up until
a certain point and then the curve just
went flat so it didn't matter if it was
an extremely extremely common word
so then
um for
extrinsic word vector evaluation so at
this point
you're now wanting to sort of say well
can we embed our word vectors in some
end user task and do they help
and do different word vectors work
better or worse than other word vectors
so this is something that we'll see a
lot of later in the class i mean in
particular
when you get on to doing assignment
three that assignment three you get to
build dependency parsers and you can
then
use word vectors in the dependency
parser and see how much they help we
don't actually make you test out
different sets of word vectors but you
could um
here's just one example of this to give
you a sense so the task of named entity
recognition is going through a piece of
text and identifying mentions of a
person name or an organization name like
a company or a location and so
if you have good word vectors um do they
help you do named entity recognition
better and the answer to that is yes so
if one starts off with a model that
simply has discrete features so it uses
word identity as features you can build
a pretty good named entity model doing
that but if you add into it word vectors
you get a better representation of the
meaning of words and so that you can
have the numbers go up quite a bit and
then you can compare different models to
see how much gain they give you in terms
of this extrinsic task
so skipping ahead
this was a question that i was asked
after class
which was
word senses because so far
we've had just
one
word
sorry for one particular string we've
got some string house and we're going to
say for each of those strings there's a
word vector
and if you think about it a bit more
that seems like it's
very
weird because actually most words um
especially common words and especially
words that have existed for a long time
actually have many meanings which are
very different so how could that be
captured if you only have one word
vector for the word because you can't
actually capture the fact that you've
got different meanings for the word
because your meaning for the word is
just one point in space one vector
and so
as an example of that
here's the word pipe
now
it's actually
but it is an old germanic
word well what kind of means does the
word pike have
um
so you can maybe just think for a minute
and think um
what were meanings the word pike has
and it actually turns out you know it
has a lot of different meanings so
so perhaps the most basic meaning is um
if you did fantasy games or something
medieval weapons um a sharp pointed
staff there's a pike um but there's a
kind of a fish that has a similar
elongated shape that's a pike um it was
used for
railroad um lines maybe that usage isn't
used much anymore but it certainly still
survives in referring to roads so this
is like when you have turnpikes we have
expressions where pike means the future
like coming down the pike
it's a position in diving
that divers do a pike
those are all now nooses
they're also verbal uses so you can pike
somebody with your pike
you know different usages might have
different currency
in australia you can also use
pike to mean that you pull out of doing
something like i reckon he's going to
pike
i don't think that usage is used in
america but lots of meanings and
actually for words that are commoner if
you start thinking words like line or
field i mean they just have even more
meanings than this so
what are we actually doing with just one
vector for a word
and
well
one way you could go is to say okay up
until now what we've done is crazy
pike has and other words have all of
these different meanings so maybe what
we should do
is have different word vectors for the
different meanings of pike so we'd have
one
word vector for the medieval pointy
weapon another word vector for the kind
of fish another word vector for the kind
of road so that they then be word sense
vectors
and you can do that i mean actually
we were working on that in the early
2010s actually even before word to vect
came out
so
this picture is a little bit small
to see
but what we were doing was for
words we work clustering
instances of a word hoping that those
clusters
so clustering the word tokens hoping
those clusters that were similar
represented sensors and then for the
clusters of word tokens we were sort of
treating them like they were separate
words and learning a word vector for
each and you know basically that
actually works so in green we have two
senses for the word bank and so there's
one sense for the word bank that's over
here where it's close to words like
banking finance transaction and
laundering and then we have another
sense for the word bank over here
whereas close to words like plateau
boundary gap territory which is the
riverbank sense of the word bank um and
for the word jaguar that's in purple um
well jq has a number of sensors and so
we have those as well so this sense down
here is um close to hunter so that's the
sort of big game animal sense of um
jaguar up the top here is being shown
close to luxury and convertibles this is
the jaguar car sense
um then jaguar here is near string um
keyboard and words like that so jaguar
is the name of a kind of keyboard um and
then this final jaguar over here is
close to software and microsoft and then
if you're old enough you'll remember
that there was an old version of mac os
so it's called jaguar um so that's then
the computer sense so basically this
does work and we can learn word vectors
for different sensors of a word but
actually this isn't the majority way
that things have been gone in practice
and
there are kind of a couple of reasons
for that i mean one is just simplicity
if you do this
it's kind of complex because you first
of all have to learn word senses and
then start learning word vectors in
terms of the word senses
but the other reason is although this
model of having word sensors um
is traditional it's what you see in
dictionaries it's commonly what's being
used in natural language processing i
mean it tends to be imperfect in its own
way because we're trying to take all the
uses of the word pike and sort of cut
them up into key different sensors where
the
difference is kind of overlapping and
it's often not clear which ones to count
as distinct so for example here right a
railroad line and a type of road well
sort of that's the same sense of pike
it's just that they're different forms
of transportation and so you know that
this could be you know a type of
transportation line and cover both of
them so it's always sort of very unclear
how you cut word meaning into
different sensors and indeed if you look
at different dictionaries everyone does
it differently
so um
it actually turns out that in practice
you can do
rather well by simply having one word
vector per word type
and what happens if you do that
well what you find
is
that
what you learn as a word vector
is
what gets referred to in fancy talk as a
super superposition of
the dif of the word vectors for the
different senses of a word um where the
word superposition means no more or less
than a weighted sum so our the vector
that we learned for pike will be a
weighted average of the vectors that you
would have learned for the medieval
weapon sense plus the fish sense plus
the road sense plus whatever other
senses that you have
where the weighting that's given to
these different sense vectors
corresponds to the frequencies of use of
the different sensors so we end up with
the
word um the vector for pike um being a
kind of an average vector
and so if you're
um
if you're
say okay you've just added up several
different vectors into an average you
might think that that's kind of useless
because you know you've lost the real
meanings of the word and you've just got
some kind of funny average vector
that's in between them
but actually
it turns out that if you use this
average vector
in applications it tends to sort of
self-disambiguate because if you say is
the word pike similar to the word for
fish
well part of this vector represents fish
the fish sense of pike and so in those
components it'll be kind of similar to
the fish vector and so yes you'll say
the um
substantia there's substantial
similarity whereas if in another um
piece of text that says you know the men
were aimed were armed with pikes and
lancers or pikes and mesas or whatever
other medieval weapons you remember well
actually
some of that meaning is in the pike
vector as well and so it'll say yeah
there's good similarity
with
mace and staff and words like that as
well and in fact we can work out which
sense of pike is intended by just sort
of seeing which
components are similar to other words
that are used in the same context
and indeed there's actually a much more
surprising result than that and this is
a result that's um jews are sanjiv
aurora
tanguma who is now on our stanford
faculty and others in 2018 and that's
the following result which i'm not
actually going to explain but um
so if you think that the vector for pike
is just a sum of the vectors
for the different sensors well
it should be
you'd think that it's just completely
impossible
to reconstruct the sense vectors from
the vector for um the word type because
normally if i say i've got two numbers
the sum of them is 17 you just have no
information as to what my two numbers
are right you can't resolve it um and
even worse if i tell you i've got three
numbers and they sum to 17
but
it turns out that when we have these
high dimensional vector spaces
that
things are so sparse in those high
dimensional vector spaces that you can
use ideas from sparse coding to actually
separate out the different sensors
providing they're relatively common
so they show in their paper that you can
start with the vector of say pike and
actually separate out components of that
vector that correspond to different
sensors of the word pike and so here's
an example at the bottom of this slide
which is for the word
it's separated out that vector into five
different sensors and so there's one
sense it's close to the words trousers
blouse waistcoat so this is the sort of
clothing sense of tie another sensors
is close to wires cables wiring
electrical so that's the sort of the
thai sense of attire used in the
electrical staff and then we have sort
of scoreline goals equalizer so this is
the sporting game sense of tie this one
also seems to in a different way evokes
sporting game sense of tie
and then there's finally this one here
maybe my music is just really bad
maybe it's because you get ties and
music when you tie notes together i
guess so you get these different senses
out of it